[Musica]
buonasera a tutti è un piacere essere
qui perché mi piace monroe questo
vocabolo alternativa il cuoco uno
nessuno centomila
questo momento è una storia che voglio
dedicare giovani che intraprendono una
carriera e il ripercorrere alcuni attimi
e dargli un senso quindi per me
alternativa è una parola importante che
racchiude in sé tante caratteristiche e
significati che portano tutti alla
possibilità di altro altri altri
alternativa ci fa respirare
ovviamente alternativa è la possibilità
di scegliere uno o l'altro alternativa è
la possibilità di mantenere il nostro
patrimonio ad ogni livello senza
disperderlo ma nello stesso tempo
alternativa è la continua ricerca di
altre strade e di evoluzione per
scendere nel campo del food
l'alternativa ci mantiene integra nelle
possibilità di scegliere nel variegato
mondo agroalimentare mantenendo le
biodiversità senza assolutamente fermare
la ricerca di strade nuovi sviluppo e
crescita alternativo in cucina e la
possibilità di gustare ricette della
tradizione rispettandole e mantenendo le
vive ma nello stesso tempo alternativa
significa anche dare spazio all'apertura
di strade nuove che consentano il
formarsi del consolidarsi di nuove
tradizioni e questo è molto importante
alternativa
sempre secondo me questo lo dico sempre
ci dovrebbe togliere dal pensiero
l'imperativo si fa così e portarci
piacevolmente al si fa anche così
questo preambolo mi porta a pensare che
oggi per me la parola alternativa si
arricchisce di significati e assume un
altro peso perché dico questo
tanti nuovi conoscono da vent'anni in tv
quindi 20 anni televisione interrotta da
chef residente conduttore autore e
quanto altro ma 20 anni da quel momento
che mi portano ad essere protagonista
della nascita e crescita di una giovane
azienda io lo chiamo giovane azienda
con 20 anni di esperienza quindi mi
piace proprio questo è dentro di me
siamo partiti da lontano
cosa facciamo nella nostra azienda
azioni sono appassionato ed etimologia
quindi azioni deriva dal latino actus a
giro per aree fare facciamo azioni
gastronomiche abbiamo una grande cucina
forse più grande di tanti ristoranti
eppure principalmente non vendiamo pasti
e non abbiamo sale ristorante il nostro
menù è composto da diversi servizi che
forniscono competenze in analisi studio
da quelli progettuali a quelle esecutive
nello specifico ci occupiamo di analisi
studio progettazione elaborazione di
format ricerca formazione redazione di
contenuti food design videoproduzioni
insomma tanto grandi tanto tanto tanti
eventi
offriamo un range ampio di servizi chi
lavora nel nostro gruppo mi piace
chiamarlo gruppo e definire il noi è un
argomento molto importante della
ristorazione sono persone con competenze
ampie che indossano la giacca bianca ma
dove nasce tutto questo per raccontarvi
ho preso spunto dal mio inizio ecco
perché dedico questo racconto
soprattutto ai giovani che iniziano la
loro carriera
lo racconta in una piccola storia che
prende spunto dall inizio ma come nasce
forse la prima volta che lo dico e
faccio outing dalla mia grande desiderio
di non fare il cuoco e adesso che lo
racconta la prima volta in 35 anni di
carriera che ammetto questa cosa qui è
uno nessuno e centomila
mi porta avanti partendo dal concetto
bellissimo che ognuno di noi è uno unico
irripetibile ancora e per fortuna penso
che dalla nascita abbiamo
caratteristiche nate doni talenti queste
attitudini vengono modificate secondo
eventi
e percorsi la scelta quello che ci
succede nella vita immagine una fitta
rete di strade conosciute e sconosciute
io sono quello che cerca sempre quelle
sconosciute è un problema nei quali
ognuno di noi diventa interprete nel
bene e nel male
per sintetizzare questo percorso che
dico che perché ho fatto un'analisi
pervenire dal tecnico ma perché perché
secondo me sono cresciuto nella musica
nell'artigianato in una famiglia
semplice ingegnosa da piccolo ho sempre
frequentato attrezzi ingegni e musica
questo mi ha portato ad essere un grande
curioso mai sazio di sperimentare e
sapere e alla fine delle scuole medie
mi venne quasi imposta la scelta della
scuola professionale non ero proprio
contento per la mia famiglia e gli
insegnanti pensarono al mio futuro dal
lavoratore mentre frequentavo
l'alberghiero questo lo dico proprio
abbraccio ho fatto il gelataio il dava
piatti l'aiutante luogo ma lo spirito
sempre lo stesso cercare sempre qualcosa
che mi facesse non riuscivo a pensare a
un'operazione se non era conseguente a
un pensiero cioè come faccio girato più
veloce come metti i gusti dove lo prendo
c'è proprio a 13 anni a 14 anni non
parlo mai di mania perché brutta
un'attenzione un'attitudine personale a
a ricercare sempre qualcosa in più e
nella mia vita le scelta ho incontrato
uno chef importante per me quelli con la
p maiuscola che mi ha fatto entrare nel
meraviglioso mondo professionale ricco
di tecnica cura della persona rispetto
del posto di lavoro degli altri degli
ospiti con una continuità incredibile
non a caso nella nostra azienda oggi c'è
scritto non quel che comincia ma quel
che persevera dopo questa bella
esperienza ancora di più la voglia di
lasciar perdere questo mestiere ne feci
altre negative incontrai chef ai quali
sono grado in egual modo perché mi
diedero modo di riflettere su chi non
sarà mai voluto diventare in futuro per
persone chiuse in un mondo quadrato che
impartivano comando imperativi con
superbia si fa così e basta
ai quali chiedevo spiegazioni e quando
mi rispondevano lo facevano con
soluzioni molte empiriche
il tutto confezionato con maleducazione
di fondo e soprattutto tanta saccenteria
ed ecco ancora la riflessione personale
quel mondo quadrato come è possibile che
ci sia una sola unica strada solo perché
si fa così mai diventerò così questo è
il mantra nel crescere sempre
ancora giovane e ancora a 24 anni siete
insegnare in scuole private pensando di
sapere l'ignorante proprio non sapeva
niente ho fatto corsi per amatori ma
questi corsi trovavo giornalisti
professionisti architetti tutte persone
con una cultura alta e io dal fuoco tra
virgolette che dobbiamo trasformare
questo luogo in altro la scuola
alberghiera di una scuola di serie b ho
iniziato a non lasciar quasi nulla al
caso per quel che potevo quindi ad ogni
elezione dopo aver preso delle legnate
terribili studiavo giorno e notte in
tutti storie ingredienti aneddoti
varianti da raccontare
questo fu quello che io chiamo il primo
seme ovvero il seme della cultura essere
consapevoli che coltivare coltivare la
nostra cultura ci permetterà di evolvere
ed iniziare a vedere il mondo un po meno
quadrato ovviamente questo era il semino
piccole nonostante sono passati tanti
anni ancora oggi sento quotidianamente
ignorante davanti all'infinito da bere
lo faccio anche nel mondo gastronomico
mi piacerebbe sapere sempre di più ma
poi il tempo è quello che c è quel che
in quel in quegli anni a 24 25 anni ho
fatto una carriera molto rapida sono
diventato consulente rai sono diventato
designer cibi o ancora tutte attività
che facciamo e quindi ho iniziato
seriamente a pensare che il cuoco avesse
nuove strade da percorrere questo mi ha
pesato tanto ma non fa niente perché io
ho messo dieci anni a far capire ai
giornalisti che non esiste solo il cuoco
della ristorazione con la stella
michelin
adesso ecco perché la chiamo azienda
giovane ci abbiamo messo dieci anni
adesso comunichiamo noi siamo casa
editrice ti diamo giornale abbiamo
portati ma i dieci anni ho fatto una
fatica immensa perché lavora 22 tutti mi
dicevano perché non è un ristorante
noi facciamo decine di progetti non
hanno abbiamo una fabbrica di ricette
da questo punto la crescita è stata
continua quindi non parto per niente del
mio percorso e vi do la mia ricetta in
tre minuti
secondo me è sempre perché non esistono
imperativi la ricetta alternativa per
percorrere nuove strade non è una
ricetta semplice sempre secondo me
essere curiosi e desiderosi del perché
essere consapevoli di sapere di non
sapere aver innestato in noi il seme
della conoscenza coltivare la cultura
saper apprezzare il sapore del sapere
sapore sapere hanno una radice unica e
bellissimo uscire dal mondo quadrato
abolire l'imperativo si fa così l'unico
imperativo che dobbiamo abolire
l'imperativo ed iniziare a pensare che
si può fare anche così uscire
dall'egocentrismo delli assoluto per
aprirsi a nuove strade condividere il
poco il tanto senza il sapere senza
dimore vedere il bicchiere sempre mezzo
viene prendere i fattori negativi gli
errori come punto di ri partenza e
rilancio avere la forza ogni volta che
accettarono vestire non restare
avvinghiati alla tradizione questo è nel
cuore come punto fermo no ma rispettarla
e non aver paura di alimentare strade
nuove che un giorno daranno vita a nuove
tradizioni se non ci sono gli innovatori
come si creano tradizione le tradizioni
sono un punto d'arrivo vanno fotografate
anche in cucina
vengo criticato tanto a in cina essere
coraggiosi di divulgare qualcosa che gli
altri non fanno senza paura di essere
critica ri avere il coraggio di non
seguire il coro con degli inevitabili
rischi ma anche giusto provare nuove
strade per avere la naturale evoluzione
che deve distinguersi dalla moda del
momento questa è un'altra cosa la moda è
un'altra cosa in cucina è essere liberi
da ciò che si sa senza farsi imbrigliare
nelle evoluzioni future
oggi non è importante soltanto saper
fare già difficile per sé ma anche
sapere quello che si sta facendo
alternativa è il coraggio di vedere
positivo nel tentativo continuo di
trovare cose nuove
dove gli altri non l'hanno ancora viste
per questo è l'ultimo punto che dai
ragazzi l'alternativa è anche saper
vedere il futuro prima ad occhi chiusi e
trasformarli in realtà grazie a tutti
voi
[Applauso]